Rupert Holmes that's who the documentary
is about I'm sorry who Rupert Holmes you
know
Rupert Holmes the singer-songwriter you
know uh the Pina Colada Song
I'm sure you do I
if you like peeing your coladas getting
caught in the rain
this morning Rupert Holmes the pop
renaissance man who's gone from working
with Barbra Streisand to composing the
famous Pina Colada Song to writing
mystery novels Holmes latest work has a
catchy title to say the least it is
called Murder your employer published by
Simon Schuster a part of Paramount
Global in which Holmes creates a school
that teaches people how to commit the
ultimate crime only for those who
deserve it home says and of course it is
just a novel but man reading this he
does make it sound very real
it's amazing to think about the fact
that when Henry Hudson came up this
River for the first time he thought he
had found a shortcut to China
and then he got to Albany
Rupert Holmes lets his devilish mind
wander at his Riverside home in Cold
Spring New York
what he's come up with is a novel about
a man who seeks revenge on his
despicable boss
murder your employer the mcmaster's
guide to homicide it's all in a good
spirit but with the intent of making
this world a better place by depriving
it of some people who really shouldn't
be here okay in the book Holmes creates
an entirely New World a kind of Hogwarts
for homicide this is McMasters it took
about five years to put all this
together we visit every place here the
Hedge house and the thorn Maze and
particularly fond of the Menagerie which
has it features a real snake pit this is
masterton replica of an entire city
block for practicing murders that are
Urban based this book was a long time
in development
labor of love
it was a labor of love it was a labor of
research because I had to invent this
this sprawling uh Universe in which I
hope that the reader would Escape Escape
is something fans of homes are very
familiar with by now I was tired of my
lady
the tune escape the Pina Colada Song
helped put him on the map in 1979.
[Music]
in the rain
and the feel of the ocean
and the taste of champagne if you if
you'd like making love at midnights
in the dunes on the cape
I'm the love that you've known for
come with me and Escape
pina colada changed your life right for
a moments when you knew
there was absolutely a moment when I had
no idea whatsoever that it was going to
be a hit
I I have to tell you I mean that's my
confession to you
um there was no bolt of lightning and I
thought this is it I've got it when he
wrote it as the legend goes Holmes had
never even tried a pina colada did you
have a pina colada after that I had more
pina coladas than anyone on the face of
the Earth because everyone thought
people are very kind that you love them
and by the way they said waitress over
here you know who this is the two pina
coladas for a long time after Holmes
feared he would only be known as the
Pina Colada guy
but he has pushed his work well beyond
pop hits the mystery of Edwin Drew music
and lyrics
writing Broadway shows and winning two
Tony Awards for it I want to thank the
hundreds of thousands of people who have
seen Edwin rude already and made each
performance unique he had already worked
closely with Barbara Streisand who cold
called him in 1974. she called me up and
said uh hi this is Barbara Streisand I
really like your record and I'd uh I'd
like to record your songs I see you do
your own arrangements so maybe you
should come out to LA and and do some
sessions and I said that is the worst
Barbra Streisand impression I've ever
heard it was I I should and it wasn't
until I got out there and that I
realized this is for Real Holmes
collaborated On songs for several of
Streisand's albums as well as two for
the 1976 film A Star is Born
[Music]
and Gold Records which Holmes displays
prominently
in his bathroom
now he writes Mysteries he is the only
person in the world to have a number one
hit Tony Awards and been honored for
mystery writing with not one but two
Edgar Awards I always wanted to write
Mysteries and uh basically thought how
can I combine storytelling and my love
of music
and then it occurred to me that if I
wrote Story songs told my stories in
three three minutes initially with
Rhymes I might be able to have my cake
and eat it too which if you're eating
cake is a perfectly sensible goal to
have it has been a lifetime of
Storytelling for Rupert Holmes which he
credits to his parents for instilling in
him at an early age
thank you
even today at the age of 75
Holmes is hardly ready to just sit back
and play out past hits I would like to
write one volume of murder your blank
for every year for the next 25 years and
then you know at 101 I think I can lay
down my pen
that sounds like a good plan yeah it's a
good plan
everybody here this morning has been
looking up the lyrics to pina colada and
reciting them by Cindy I think knows
them by heart he does
um Rupert Holmes is a pen name adopted
because of Sherlock
whoa and his commitment to Mysteries
and the song is in our head